hope he's doing good job Billy no jazz
hey Jim hey Sam this is bruise from one
two three warehouse just a new client
I've added to our portfolio I know he's
just a small fish but still fun to reel
in I'm not a small fish oh yeah you are
of course Bruce welcome to Royals I ate
here once before well then welcome back
yep just pitching Bruce here some tag
lines you know closing the deal you used
to do that want to sit in no Tim I can't
but you've got this Bruce you're in
excellent hands enjoy your meals fellas
it's on me oh not the booze though so I
was wrong he's he's not gonna join us no
worries I can do it myself uh so we see
Beauty shots of your wonderful
appliances a family walks through the
store holding a map the announcer comes
on one two three warehouse where's the
warehouse it's as easy as one two three
where the house it's going to seem like
they're lost in the storm okay you know
like that here's another one one two
three warehouse it's as easy as ABC
warehouse my main competitor is ABC
warehouse that's insane
all right we'll just take the off their
check and then give them a free dessert
okay thanks Darren hey don't grab me I
didn't grab you you looked away when I
was talking to you I'm not gonna
apologize for something that I didn't do
you grabbed my shirt shirt so you admit
that I didn't grab yeah gentlemen some
wines for the table sorry to interrupt
but how about something like one two
three warehouse you can count on us I
love it because you can count on one two
three yeah that's perfect
it is it is perfect Sam come back tell
me you didn't get a rush from there
clients are coming in now and way better
than this guy trust him hey Tim I'm not
coming back look in ten years I'm gonna
be managing four of these restaurants
and hopefully Kremlin duvet is the
biggest ad agency in Detroit but Tim I
can't gamble on hopefully cuz in ten
years and my kid's gonna be nine and if
he's anything like me he's gonna need
braces for his legs
cuz it's thick so big good luck buddy I
love you I okay
well we can't use you can count on us
for legal reasons plus I refuse to do
that
but I'll come up with something just as
good
[Music]
you